je vous présente la feuille de
recensement de marianne thérèse ombeline
gonnot de montbrun veuve d'henri paul un
panneau des bassins qui a été établie à
cette pole en 1842 marianne thérèse
ombeline gonnot de montbrun aînés en
1755 à l'âge de 15 ans la riche
héritière descendante de françoise
châtelain épouse henri paul un panneau
des bastaings le ménage eu neuf enfants
et tous ont eu une situation élevé henri
paul un panneau des bassins meurt en
1800 et il laisse son épouse âgée de 46
ans à la tête d'un immense domaine
elle va s'attacher à le fructifier à
l'administrer elle même jusqu'à l'âge de
67 ans et son fils charles andré va
prendre la relève
l'exploitation du domaine repose
essentiellement sur le travail des
esclaves dont les tâches sont organisés
et spécialisés des régisseurs blanc deux
sont indiquées sur la feuille de
recensement assure l'encadrement de
toutes de l'ensemble des travaux un
niveau inférieur il existe un
encadrement en noir avec à sa tête le
commandeur un esclave
né dans l'île cette feuille de
recensement dresse un tableau d'une des
plus grandes propriétés de l'île du
milieu du 19e siècle on retrouve mention
des propriétés foncières de saint paul
saint gilles du bernica est également
des esclaves qui sont au nombre de 4 119
la tradition orale présente une femme
d'une cruauté sadique envers ses
esclaves alors que de nombreux
contemporains ont laissé des témoignages
d'une femme
le cran demande